henri sterdyniak bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors le
site de l'usiné bridgestone à béthune va
donc fermer ses portes
pourquoi selon vous la direction de
bridgestone va fermer la porte pour
reprendre les mots de la ministre au
plan de sauvetage de merci parce que
l'entreprise est notre prise
multinationale a fait plan annuel à des
civils n'étaient plus leur entame plus
compétitif par rapport aux autres usines
continental
elle a refusé malgré les promesses
elle a refusé de changer ce plan ont
continué à produire depuis
depuis c'est une décision stratégique
mois de la ferme que la d6 l'entreprise
a pris 20 septembre a décidé de lui un
certain temps dans le vestiaire à bout à
bout
elle a refusé contre janvier ses plans
et la pression du parce que vous lisiez
le géant japonais du pneumatique a dit
ferme il cite considérant que le marché
est en surcapacité ce constat que ne
partage pas le le gouvernement qu'en
est-il selon vous une question semble
surcapacités c'est un choix l'entreprise
al soir développer ses activités à b ou
dans d'autres pays elle a considéré je
n'étais musique il fallait fermer
considération de tous doux contre le
fait également que céline relativement
il faut investir beaucoup la mettre pour
la remontée ils ont préféré investir
dans les pays à bas salaires leur a
proposé par ailleurs et
subventions de l'union européenne par le
ca consultables dans les pires des goûts
de tout ça il a fait son choix il ya
cinq ans on arrête de respirer mais le
problème c'est que les salariés seraient
pas de décision non vie le gouvernement
français n'était pas au courant de cette
histoire et le plus tard possible
à ce moment là notre il ya passé trop
tard les plans sont très vieux produit à
l'heure alors l'avenir des ouvriers
on y revient dans un instant mais avant
beaucoup de réactions politiques 1 le
bras de fer continue pour le conseiller
régional des hauts de france xavier
bertrand selon marine le pen je la cite
ces fameux cette fermeture et l'échec
d'un état sans vision sans volonté
politique d' inverser la tendance la
désindustrialisation continuera l'état
selon vous aurait-il pu s'y prendre
différemment dans ce dossier ça pose la
question effectivement de la
désindustrialisation les grand nombre
d'entreprises choisissent d'ailleurs il
ya plus bas salaires
ce soit les deux reprises contre ça et
être une stratégie le gouvernement n'a
pas de stratégie d'un côté il faut
imposer aux grandes entreprises d'avoir
des plans à moyen terme sur le
développement propre entreprise plans
ouverts et sans doute à discuter avec
les syndicats pour imposer aux
entreprises qu'il estime devoir permet
d'avoir des plans de reconversion
industrielle surtout il faut avoir une
politique industrielle de long terme
malka vernement la situation actuelle
c'est tout on a terminé à la dernière
minute comme l'entreprise annonce qu
effectivement elle va fermer cinq ans
pour discuter avec l'entreprise de ses
porteurs à moyen terme
dire que l'entreprise disent qu'il ya un
mois oui je continue à investir dans
l'entreprise ou non je continue j'arrête
investir habitude on aime ces deux là on
arrive à la dernière minute
naturellement la question est posée
c'est hier qu'on doit rester nationale
de soutenir globalement algéro cola en
tout cas ce sont le disait 863 employés
concernés leur famille un ami espagnol
une hache et a dit que le gouvernement
allait maintenant travailler sur les
scénarios de reprise pour conclure est
ce que les salariés peuvent voir de
l'espoir qu'elles pourraient être les
perspectives à venir est le problème des
salariés maintenant c'est de réussir à
faire un rapport de force avec leur
ancienne entre lui et avec le
gouvernement pour que l'effectif est le
maximum de garanties
à côté des dames de te faire venir un
autre entreprise en particulier par
l'entreprise patrick d'autres pas
d'avoir des garanties que les salariés
les plus jeunes sont effectivement
embauchés dans d'autres entreprises de
la région sachant que le risque c'est
que ça fasse au détriment d'autres
par ailleurs c'est pas une solution
géniale un certain nombre de bénéficier
de retraite faut que bridgestone pays se
soient pas la charge de liquider
[Musique]
physiquement ce serait de le
gouvernement annonce clairement que la
subventionner fortement notre fils qui
voudraient s'installer là où il faut
faire très attention parce que le risque
et les faire venir
comme souvent est une entreprise à jean
simplement chasseuse de primes comme
vite repris peu avant tout avec le
périnée
depuis donc il faut une entreprise
dominée d inscrire autant de paires se
veut dans la transition écologique une
entreprise pour les batteries pour les
voitures et liquides ou notre clinique
qui se lance dans un vallon revienne
quelque chose qui soit durable et sa
demande effectivement là aussi l'état
suivra ça de près en tout cas merci à
vous et henri sterdyniak d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france je le
rappelle vous êtes économiste à la fcf